شبه جزيره القرم في صداره المشهد في
اوكرانيا مره اخرى باعلان سلطاتها
المواليه لروسيا اسقط صواريخ في مضيق
الكرش مع نفي وقوع اي اضرار بجسر القرن
تعلن الدفاع الروسيه محاوله اوكرانيه لشن
الهجوم على الجسر بصواريخ اس 200
واعتراضها وتحدثت مصادر الروسيه عن كونها
الصواريخ معدله لتصبح هجوميه بينما اشارت
سلطات القرمه لروسيا الى ان الاجهزه
الامنيه الروسيه قامت بتشكيل ستار دخاني
على جسر القرم المسيرات عنوان المرحله
ايضا اتعرضت شبه جزيره القرم وفق الدفاع
الروسيه لهجمات بطائره مسيره اوكرانيه
وكان الامر نفسه في مقاطعتي كلوغا
وبالجرود الروسيتين
المتحدثه باسم قياده عمليات الجنوب في
الجيش الاوكراني قالت ان موسم التفجيرات
في القرن سيستمر
لقد اشار الجيش الى ان موسم التفجيرات في
القرن سيستمر بالفعل وستظل شبه جزيره
القرم مضطربه حتى تحريرها اما الخارجيه
الروسيه فوصفت الهجمات على جسر القرن
بالارهابيه وقالت انها لن تفقدون رد لكن
كيف قطعت هذه الصواريخ مسافات طويله وصولا
الى هناك تساؤل ياتي بينما يقرا محللون ما
يحدث في كونه استراتيجيه اوكرانيه تعتمد
مبدا الرضع والضغط مقابل الضغط تنشر
الاستخبارات الاوكرانيه في ظل الحرب
الاعلاميه على صفحتها على التيليجرام
فيديو لمسيره مائيه وعمليات هجوميه وتقول
دون تفاصيل انها لتدمير من سمتهم غزه
موسكو على الارض وفي الهواء وفي الماء
لكنك تقر بالمقابل بالتعرض مناطق عديده في
البلاد لاكثر من ثلاث نهاره روسيه وقصف
مكثف خلال ساعات بصواريخ مجنحه على الجهه
الاخرى تعلن الدفاع الروسيه
دفعه الجويه من تدمير نحو 30 مسيره
واستهداف تمركز القوات والمعدات
الاوكرانيه في اكثر من 100 منطقه تتحدث
موسكو عن ضربه باسلحه جويه عاليه الدقه
بعيده المدى على مطار عسكري بالقرب من
كولومبيا في منطقه ايفانو
وضربها مقر القياده الاماميه للفيلق
العاشر للقوات الاوكرانيه بالقرب من مدينه
اوريخوفا بمنطقه
اما الاركان الاوكرانيه فتقول ان قوتها
مستمره في الهجوم على محوري
وانها صدت هجمات روسيه في مقاطعه
معطيات الحرب تبدو رياحها لا تجري كما
خططت له القياده الاوكرانيه
اعلن اقاله رؤساء مراكز التجنيد العسكري
في عموم البلاد فنظام التجنيد يجب ان يدار
من قبل اشخاص يعرفون جيدا ما هي الحرب حسب
تعبيره والحرب لا تبدو محصوره مع
امتداداتها الجغرافيه وتداعيتها ورسائلها
فتدريبات لقوه اسطول الشمال في الجيش
الروسي انطلقت وفق الدفاع الروسيه يشارك
فيها اكثر من ثمانيه الاف جندي وعشرين
سفينه حربيه اضافه الى غواصات وسفن دعم